if they have plants I would get like a
couple of like cacti which is plural for
cactus sure I knew that yeah I didn't
know that somebody corrected me I was
like back elected you with character I
think that Europeans left to correct
Hudson stocks right he is no good
true what are you gonna do we got drunk
chick on a tear you never know what's
gonna happen mrs. Bute ah that's true
it's just like these stale pretzels
absolutely salty and filling yeah
nothing mind you me what's up everybody
welcome to stupid questions with Chris
de Stefano I'm with Michelle buteau
actress comedian just gonna show called
late night whenever don't go podcast you
post it I make a check tell you what
else you got
I got titties I like Rosie and hummus
yes I haven't felt it but they look do
you want feel it okay are you telling me
to do yes do it
oh wow yeah that is nice wait that's
yeah if you could shower in any like
breakfast drink what would you shower
all day wow I guess Terry you want to
bathe in that brunch oh yes the
parties
here's a stupid question what's the
strangest thing you've ever bought or
seen at a convenience store oh my god a
convenience I'm so glad you asked me
these questions I saw that um this one
convenience store where was it like
upstate New York okay
it was a tampon that is specifically
made for like alcohol
what do you mean like you what do you
mean specifically made for alcohol so
like it was alcohol or Tampa that's how
you get that's how you getting drunk
yeah without thinking and it's just for
women or its fermented like what do you
mean live your life girl Wow I don't
know you Christopher I don't know how
flexible you is I mean that's wow that
is weird I've never seen anything quite
that weird communes store well you
weren't looking for tampons if you could
switch places with another comedian who
would it be first person that popped
into my mind was Joan Rivers yeah that's
a good one yeah when she had her
late-night talk show and everyone
on her I would just like love to go back
in time and be like but also like I
watch Whoopi Goldberg on the view and I
don't know she's high I don't know if
she's wearing a bra I don't care she is
so smart and I know that she has a
Japanese toilet and I just like
interesting would I feel like if I had a
Japanese toilet cleaning my bum you know
like the right ways notes and crannies
and crevices I might be smarter too I
guess I could be Joy Behar I sound like
her right we have the same voice I would
just put on a wig and I'm Joy Behar yeah
that's your like drag alias you see
that's a good that's a stupid yeah drank
drank dub I don't think it's stupid I
think it's beautiful no I think it's
beautiful Joe you have a good time here
super questions is that a stupid
question
it can't be steal it but I'm just
looking for obviously fun no no no I'm
so much fun it's nice hanging out with
you like not in the back of a comedy
club waiting to go on yeah yeah we got
your stupid gifts too stupid gifts most
people just get one but you got to don't
you talk about my debts um yes first
this is a bottle of Rose a did you know
how much you love rose a yes and then
you always say hey there's cow hey there
you go yeah hey hey yeah and that and
that gift is for you
hey and Rosie and it rhymes still there
I mean is this real Rosie
you